[Musique]
les sessions de répétitions s'enchaînent
pas le blanc pour le second jour du
festival beau bart un festival
éclectique aux styles musicaux aussi
variés qu'originaux ce soir les fat
bastard grandes bandes seront sur scène
musiciens pour une fanfare rock est un
objectif
une invitation au voyage c'est un peu le
propos emmener les gens dans notre nom
notre vaisseau est évoquée dans
différentes directions en amenant les
gens avec nous et et cia si l'alchimie
se fait ça prend au voyage encore plus
loin et en 15 ans les frontières en
cassant les barrières en essayant de ne
pas rester plutôt rare dumas nous voila
voila on sera loin du bateau on
s'éloigne par un prologue hier soir pour
l'ouverture du festival entre 250 et 300
personnes ont fait le déplacement
c'est l'association locale en chantier
qui est à l'origine de l'événement
son objectif fournir à leblanc de
nombreuses animations culturelles
au départ l'association a créé plusieurs
événements en fait dans la ville dans la
salle des fêtes de la ville du blanc et
au bout de dix ans
l'association a eu envie de faire un
festival est donc ces petits événements
donc on a une soirée cabaret en hiver ne
serait plus musique électro au mois de
mai juin continue en fait de perdurer on
fait tous les ans et de soirée en plus
du festival
si les amateurs de musique sont servis
leurs enfants ne sont pas en reste les
bénévoles préparent un espace qui leur
est dédié au programme jeux d'eau ou
encore atelier peinture il ya de plus en
plus d'enfants sur les festivals parce
que c'est pas parce qu'on a 30 ans et
qu'on a des enfants sont sortis de chez
nous et s'il ya des animations pour les
enfants
du coup on est d'autant plus amenés à y
venir enfin moi je suis bénévole sur le
festival bobards depuis maintenant cinq
ans j'ai trois filles et tous les ans je
viens avec les filles et ça se passe
super bien parce que c'est un festival
vachement familiale un festival familial
qui achève ce soir sa sixième édition
les concerts débuteront à partir de
20h30 avec les frissonne ce groupe de
rock local
[Musique]
blogue
nous voici avec wilfrid robin
responsable du festival beau barth où il
faut drogba bonsoir bonsoir
alors on l'a vu ce sont des styles de
musique assez variés assez éclectique
qui sont représentés ici
du coup on peut se demander quelle est
l'adn du festival alors l'adn du
festival c'est d'abord une bande de
copains qui avaient envie de créer un
événement sur son territoire voilà donc
en 2009 on a réveillé une asso qui était
un peu dormantes et pendant on a fait un
peu nos preuves pendant quelques années
sur des petits événements et depuis 2013
on organise le festival bart alors dans
le paysage des festivals de musique en
france est important d'avoir des petits
festivals comme celui ci bah oui et
surtout dans l'été des territoires
ruraux comme les nôtres qui peuvent être
un peu enclavé en tout cas voilà sur un
territoire un peu compliqué sud de la
région à côté d'une nouvelle région d'un
autre département voilà c'est pas
évident donc il nous sommes qu'il faut
faire vivre aussi des petits événements
alors tout à l'heure il ya des
parachutistes de l'école de parachutisme
du blanc qui vont atterrir à côté de la
scène
alors finalement vos bartz et pas que de
la musique eh ben on n'oublie pas le
local
il ya une banderole sur la sauvegarde la
maternité il ya une école on a la chance
d'avoir un centre de le fp l'école
française de parachutisme au blanc donc
mal à ils sont en train d'atterrir ils
sont au dessus de nous en fait en train
d'atterrir
voilà donc on essaie aussi va de
travailler avec le local mais aussi
également dans la restauration faire
voilà on est aussi implanté sur un
territoire
alors hier soir pour l'ouverture du
festival vous avez aussi entre 250 et
300 personnes ce soir vous espérer mieux
alors on espère mieux on est tous sur
notre petite jauge hier soir voilà
fallait pas moins on espère on espère
500 personnes voilà je l'annonçais on
espère 500 personnes ce soir est
vraiment alors est-ce qu'on retrouvera
festival beaux bars en 2019 pour une
septième édition
alors pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
raison en france pendant sera plus déjà
demain matin on avis non évidemment
c'est toujours une histoire de budget
voilà jusque là on arrive à équilibrer
tout juste festival mais voilà ça suffit
pour le faire vivre
en tout cas c'est l'idée même merci
beaucoup il fred robin d'avoir été notre
invité vous êtes je le rappelle
responsables du festival boogaerts qui
touche à sa fin ce soir avec les
concerts qui débute à partir de 20h30